Einstein in 1905 was in some ways really
disadvantaged and in some ways I think
he himself would have said he had this
great opportunity he was disadvantaged
because for a variety of reasons he
completely you know failed to get the
kind of university job or really entry
into graduate school as it was then not
quite the way we do it now after he
finished his physics degree at switz ins
leading technical institution the the
Polytechnic in Zurich he just keep
alienated his professors he didn't
bother paying attention to things he
wasn't interested in all that you know
the kind of student you would expect
Einstein to be so I didn't get any help
from him when he graduated and he was in
the wilderness he taught algebra to two
high school students for a while that
must have gone really well can you
imagine being quemic on Einsteins you
know saying I I couldn't figure out a
quadratic equation under Einsteins tool
is very embarrassing
um so his disadvantage on the other hand
he got this job in the Patent Office
where he was looking at technical
material all the time he was learning to
visualize physical physical situations
and he had um partly because he didn't
really he wasn't really a great family
man he spent really a lot of time even
though he's married and had a young son
he had great freedom to just think and I
believe that that one of the things you
see in Einstein after he gets a patent
office job and really starts settling
into being a sort of grown-up um he
really starts developing the
characteristic you would have for the
rest of his life which is this
extraordinary ability to focus no matter
what was going on around him